[Music]
foreign
good morning further action against
Russia more diplomacy between nations
but the conflict on the ground in
Ukraine intensifies President Joe Biden
has reassured Ukraine of his support and
promised more funding and in an address
to the nation president zielinski has
urged ukrainians not to retreat these
are the latest developments
visa and MasterCard have suspended
operations in Russia credit and debit
cards issued by Russian banks will no
longer work outside the country
meanwhile in a 30-minute phone call with
President zielinski last night Joe Biden
reiterated his commitment to provide
security humanitarian and economic
assistance to Ukraine
while here in the UK Boris Johnson has
unveiled a six-point plan that he hopes
world leaders will follow to ensure
Russia fails in its invasion of Ukraine
including mobilizing an international
humanitarian coalition
and all the while the humanitarian
crisis grows Aid agencies estimate that
the number of Ukrainian refugees could
reach one and a half million this
weekend
as Ukrainian cities face a continued
Russian Siege Sally Lockwood has the
latest on the crisis
world has clamored to show its support
for Ukraine but on the ground the fight
is theirs and theirs alone
Russian forces are now said to be in
control of this military base in the
southern city of kurzen
president zielinski seeking to boy a
beleaguered Nation as Russian forces
Advance towards the third Nuclear Power
Plant
Ukraine which we know love protects and
will not give up to any enemy
also believe me it is a special heroism
to protest when your city is occupied
even temporarily
when you don't have a weapon and in
response you receive gunshots and you
don't run
Capital overhead Remains the most
contentious issue Ukraine claims this
video shows a Russian helicopter being
shot down
president zielinski has repeatedly
appealed to the U.S and NATO to
establish a no-fly zone
but Putin's latest threat that this
would be viewed as participation in the
conflict has done little to change
Western leaders Minds
in a meeting at a Polish border crossing
with the U.S Secretary of State
Ukraine's foreign minister vowed to win
this war if we lose the skies
there will be much much more blood on
the ground and that will be the blood of
civilians and I don't want anyone to
share responsibility for their blood
ultimately their strength their result
their determination
backed by uh by the United States and
backed by the world is going to prevail
a new economic blow to Russia this time
from visa and MasterCard suspending
their operations in Russia
and a fresh diplomatic attempt from
Israel's prime minister
in a backdrop of anti-war protests at
home naftali Bennett flew secretly to
Moscow on Saturday for a three-hour
meeting with Vladimir Putin then on to
Berlin for talks with the German
Chancellor
[Music]
for people here in the southern region
of mariopol Escape isn't even an option
plans for a humanitarian Corridor still
on hold after Russia violated an agreed
ceasefire but Israel a country with good
relations on both sides could now prove
vital in finding a desperately needed
breakthrough Sally Lockwood Sky News
well British Military Intelligence says
that Russian forces were targeting
populated areas in Ukraine but that the
strength of resistance is slowing the
Russian Advance within the last hour the
ministry of Defense has tweeted this
update the scale and strength of
Ukrainian resistance continues to
surprise Russia it has responded by
targeting populated areas in multiple
locations including kharkiv sharanahov
and mariopol this is likely to represent
an effort to break Ukrainian morale
Russia has previously used similar
tactics in chechnya in 1999 in Syria in
2016 employing both air and ground-based
Munitions Russian supply lines
reportedly continue to be targeted
slowing the rate of advance of their
Ground Forces there is a realistic
possibility that Russia is now
attempting to conceal fuel trucks as
regular support trucks to minimize
losses
well about one and a half million people
are expected to have fled Ukraine by the
end of today with Poland taking in more
than 780 000 refugees so far and that
number continues to grow a little
earlier I spoke to Chris Meltzer from
the UN Refugee agency who said this is
an international situation and countries
need to continue showing solidarity
this might go on for many weeks and
that's why we're asking for the
solidarity
um the people in Poland but also in
Romania and Hungary and Slovakia even in
little mordovia that accepted much more
than one hundred thousand refugees these
countries are showing a lot of
solidarity but we must see this this is
not a Ukrainian Poland and not Ukrainian
Romanian crisis this is at least a
European crisis actually an
international crisis and that's why
these countries need help and solidarity
like the people need help and solidarity
that's bringing Adam Parsons who's in
live in Western Ukraine and Adam it was
it was so interesting talking to Chris
there he's a representative from the
unhcr who said they've never experienced
numbers like this in such a small time
frame even comparing it to the rohingya
and saying that it was nothing that was
nothing compared to what they're seeing
now
yeah the numbers flooding out of Ukraine
are absolutely extraordinary I think we
will hit that one and a half million
figure today that we're looking at about
a couple hundred thousand people a day
going out of this country I think you
have to put this into some kind of
context you're talking about about three
and a half percent of the population
leaving their own country over the
course of just over a week it's an
extraordinary movement of people and
also that figure doesn't tell the whole
story because that is about refugees
that's people leaving Ukraine to seek
refuge in another country there are
probably as many people again who are
simply displaced within Ukraine who have
left kharkiv or or Kiev or marry apple
or wherever it might be in order to seek
sanctuary and potentially here in in
Western Ukraine where you are much
further from the fighting so the
disruption to this country is absolutely
colossal and I think interesting hearing
that the military intelligence
assessment I think we are seeing
something play out here which is that
bluntly Ukraine's armed resistance has
been much much stronger and more
Resolute than the World perhaps
predicted and at the same time Russia's
ability as a super military power on the
ground has been worse than we predicted
why might that be well I think for one
thing Ukraine has an enormous army with
a lot of reservists and an incredible
amount of spirit we were filming over
the past day or so outside a recruitment
station that the queue's going on
hundreds of people outside one station
replicated across this nation people are
queuing up to join to fight and to
defend their country at the same time
you have Russian forces who are using a
lot of equipment that is obsolete I
think there is a question about morale
there's plenty of young soldiers who
didn't realize they were coming into a
war zone don't particularly want to be
here and and evidently rushes back plans
are nowhere near as advanced as we
expected now let's not be naive Russia
has some enormous Weaponry it is
continuing to attack strategically
important places it's going to advancing
on another nuclear power station on
hydro facilities and president zielinski
in his address last night was emphatic
telling his people to fight back at the
same time he wants diplomatic efforts
whether that is from Israel from the
United States from Germany from the UK
what he really wants is a no-fly zone
from NATO at the moment he's not getting
it and he says that is crucial to saving
his country
Adam thank you so much
Well the West has refused to impose that
no-fly zone above Ukraine despite
repeated calls from president zielinski
this guy's Trevor Phillips has been
speaking to Kurt volcker who's a former
U.S ambassador ambassador to Nato and
was the special representative for
Ukraine during Donald Trump's
Administration
first off we've done this in the past
we've executed no-fly zones we've done
it over the Kurdish areas in Iraq for
example and Saddam Hussein was attacking
that so we know how to do this there is
a protocol for this secondly we make
very clear this is for humanitarian
purposes only we are there to prevent
attacks on the civilian population from
the air and we do this over Kiev in
Western Ukraine so it's limited
geographically we are not coming close
to Russian borders and we make very
clear the Rules of Engagement we will
not be striking any ground targets any
Russian forces unless fired upon and we
will not be striking any Russian
aircraft or helicopters provided they
remain outside the zone and if they
enter the Zone then there's a protocol
of escalating uh tactics to to escort
them out but if they refuse then there
would be the prospect of firing on them
but many ways to avoid that and I think
the Russians will understand this as
well they might test us but then I think
they don't want to draw us into a larger
conflict either
well let me um push back a little bit on
that do you really think that Mr Putin
is going to play by rules that NATO has
set out he hasn't been interested in
NATO what NATO has had to say about
anything thus far
yeah I think uh it's force that he
respects it's force that he listens to
uh not
um the rules that are stated so if he
sees that we are doing it and we are
prepared to follow through I think he
will adjust
well let's talk about no-fly zones and
we're joined Now by a former senior
Royal Air Force officer Air Marshal Ed
Stringer Ed good morning Gene thank you
so much for talking to us
you you've been involved in no-fly zones
um extensively let's just talk you know
Basics here what is a no-fly zone
and if I zone is where you delineate an
area of airspace uh and you essentially
say that cannot be used for military
purposes what that tends to mean is it
can't be used
um for for any purposes at all
but what I would say listening to that
clip I think needs clarifying is this is
not some form of benign air policing
what you have to do is sanitize that
anything that can control in that
airspace that will be surface-to-air
missiles etc etc Radars and so all the
no-fly zones I've been involved in have
been an extensive operation to suppress
an opposition's ability to control
airspace so I think listening to that it
will be quite difficult to set these
discrete boundaries and say you can do
this but you can't do that
so it's quite quite an aggressive action
that would be needed to delineate that
and have said and keep it clear
yes it's an aggressive action and it it
it it is a proper military operation it
just happens to be run by people who
tend to wear blue uniforms not not khaki
ones but it involves a lot of activity
air to ground as I say it is not just
some form of benign air policing and
escorting bad aircraft out of the area
and telling them not to do it again so
essentially what you're doing here is uh
uh is an act of war and has to be has to
be considered that way so if if we were
to set up a no-fly zone would that be
seen as an escalation because Putin has
said that exactly that yesterday
there's an escalation in this in this
context and I was involved in the
notification that was just mentioned in
humanitarian one in Northern Iraq which
could absolutely be described as a
humanitarian operation against if you
like an enemy Saddam as saying that we
had just vanquished in uh in Kuwait I
think this is a very different
geopolitical situation it would also be
a very different no-fly zone wouldn't it
well yes and exactly and we're up
against you know a great military power
uh that would be Russia so so this idea
that somehow we we could carve out areas
and call this just humanitarian it would
be seen by Russia as Putin has said uh
as an act by NATO to fundamentally limit
its military uh its military operations
and every time that this has been
mentioned not every time but frequently
the argument is we can't do that because
that would result in us shooting down
Russian planes
would that be the end game of a no-fly
zone
yeah that that ultimate is what he says
to be able to do
um and uh with Rules of Engagement with
the congested airspace that there that
there would be with the just the scale
and the range the quality of uh
equipment that both sides would put
forward
um you could see this escalating uh very
rapidly into uh some form of great air
conflict uh uh over Ukraine and as I say
it would drag in all the ground elements
uh as well
did you have to shoot many planes down
in in the no-fly zones over Iraq well
Saddam Hussein didn't have much of it
didn't have much of an Air Force a lot
of it had been removed during the Gulf
War but what he tried to do was use
ground-based systems and did end up uh
firing at uh the Coalition aircraft
quite extensively which resulted in
quite a serious campaign to suppress his
enemy air defenses which is a technical
phrase for bombing his stuff on the
ground
what about ground-based artillery if
you're policing the airspace you're not
going to stop those are you
no that's the point so you could
actually say here you could easily
postulate a case where uh even if your
note fly zone was successful you could
be flying top cover and watching the
sort of horrendous scenes on the ground
that we're seeing at the moment while
actually stopping the ukrainians flying
their effective drones because a no-fly
zone is a no-fly zone
so would it be more effective than
sending in weapons which is what we're
doing now
effective in what sense
and I can absolutely see and I do
sympathize with why zelenski is asking
for a no-fly zone because he knows that
is NATO getting involved in this
conflict
um if you want to talk about
Effectiveness in stopping Russian ground
operations then supplying the sort of uh
drones and light anti-tank weaponry and
similar systems on which we've been
trained in the ukrainians now for
whatever five to ten years I think would
help them conduct the ground operation
best
so given your experience if we were to
implement a no-fly zone as zielinski
keeps asking us to do that would be an
escalation and do you think that would
lead to an all-out World War III
it would be an escalation
I suspect it would give Putin the out he
craves and that he could now craft the
narrative
that this is now NATO revealing its true
colors and trying to attack Russia and
take Ukraine and he would hope that that
would Galvanize the Russian population
at the moment must be questioning why it
has got uh involved in this operation
but of course
um yeah I I could see why the ukrainians
would want it and I could see
humanitarian case and I can see how that
will become compelling so you could see
that there'll be a force of public
opinion in the west that would demand
that that something would be done but
yes it will be an escalation and if
Putin escalates and given his track
record at the moment then there is it is
quite easy to sketch a path to a full-on
conflict between NATO and Russia
okay a martial Ed string and thank you
so much for talking to us this morning
thank you
well let's talk about what's happening
on the ground because intense fighting
continues between those Ukrainian and
Russian forces Russia was accused of
breaking a temporary ceasefire in the
encircled cities of Marriott
after evacuation routes were set up to
allow civilians to escape the fighting
in the southwest of the country Russian
forces continue to advance on the city
of mikhaila mikolov close to the crucial
economic Hub of Odessa around the
capital the governor of the Kiev region
says Russian forces have taken a
psychiatric hospital in borodianca with
more than 600 patients inside while
north of Kiev the Ukrainian Ministry of
Defense claims it shut down a Russian
helicopter near kosarovichi from Kiev
our special correspondent Alex Crawford
reports on the fight for the capital
but the Russian troops are getting
closer and closer to the capital
they're now only eight kilometers away
with the Ukrainian military desperately
trying to stop Russian soldiers who are
pressing into the center of urban
the sounds of street by street fighting
and thud of war is a constant inside the
town
and in the middle of this all there are
terrified civilians hundreds gingerly
making their way across a bombed Bridge
hastily patched together with a
makeshift walkway
most are women and children gripping
each other's hands holding their pets
close
among them two many elderly clasping the
only possessions they've managed to grab
it's all they have left in the world now
there are Ukrainian soldiers trying to
guide them across they know they're just
ahead of the advancing Russian troops
and the window to get them to safety is
narrowing you see that Putin attacking
children Putin attacking elderly people
putting attack in women's and this is no
any rules of law he is a military crime
there's no humanitarian Corridor here
and no real safe place this is only the
next staging post
sounds of War aren't lessening instead
they're getting louder and following
them
they're exhausted and spent and often
weeping with relief or just glad to be
alive
in a car and we saw this better Russian
better
he's he's striking on us and we
his Gods now save us God save us
the Russian army is leaving a trail of
Despair and destruction as it cuts its
way through to the capital
aerial footage of butcher another town
on the outskirts of Kiev showed burning
vehicles and abandoned Russian Hardware
dream of Ukrainian soldiers emerge from
Urban looking drained of all energy and
defeated
it looked like it had been a tough
battle
s picking up the fight know it will not
be easy and some who escaped had hair
raising tails
did you see the Russian soldiers yeah
they closed off you saw them how many
were there what they what were they
doing I saw just like maybe two or three
people and there was just so I just like
to run from there I didn't wanted to
watch it
can you work out what they're trying to
attack are they attacking everything
just something special I I guess they
shouldn't everything they see so
so yeah
what have they tied you up with
oh my gosh did they they think they
think you were Russian uh probably yes
but we have all documents we can prove
that we are not Russians we are
ukrainians a Ukrainian Soldier
investigates and questions them and they
produce their passports any young man
not fighting is viewed with great
suspicion
but he's satisfied they are ukrainians
and cuts him free
those who fled are now desperately
hoping they can reach sanctuary
it seems the Russian military is moving
relentlessly forward and they're being
transported into the capital a few
kilometers away where they fear they'll
be next
year there's non-stop work to try to
shore up defenses and protect themselves
amidst increasingly strident demands for
International Help
we are on our own land in our country
and we will fight for this country
in every town in Erie city on each
street from the each building we are
ready and we will fight because we are
[Applause]
the truth on our side and they got on
our side
so we will win
they're calling for a no-fly zone but
with the world looking on now all they
can do is wait for an army they fear
will inevitably arrive Alex Crawford Sky
News Kiev
visa and MasterCard are suspending
operations in Russia meaning credits and
debit cards issued by Russian banks will
no longer work outside the country let's
bring in our Milena vaselinovic who's in
The Newsroom for us this morning morning
Milano to this news breaking overnight
morning Kimberly yes it's just the
latest in the raft of economic sanctions
are leveled against Russia MasterCard
said that their cards issued in Russia
will no longer work in their system
equally cars issued abroad will no
longer be accepted by Russian acms and
in Russian shops and the company did say
they didn't take this decision lightly
considering they've been operating in
Russia for more than 25 years similarly
Visa said that they were in talks to
suspend all transactions in the country
in the coming days and their CEO said
this was due to Russia's invasion of
Ukraine now considering that those two
companies handle more than 90 percent of
all debit and credit card transactions
outside of China this is going to be
very significant and earlier on Saturday
we've also heard that PayPal also has
shut down their operations in the
country and it comes after Swift that
into bank and Global messaging system
has cut out a number of Russian
financial institutions from their
operations and that will make it
incredibly hard to make international
payments out of Russia or to Russia and
this is all having a really detrimental
effect on the Russian economy the
national currency of Ruble has tumbled
down by more than a third to a record
low and the people who are really
feeling this are the ordinary Russian
citizens they're experiencing high
levels of inflation long queues in front
of ACM so they are really feeling this
economic pain now the thinking Behind
These Western sanctions is that that
will compel Russian President Putin to
get to the negotiating table perhaps
some sort of a compromise over Ukraine
but really so so far there doesn't seem
to be any sign of that happening at all
Ena thank you
well Boris Johnson has claimed Vladimir
Putin is trying to rewrite the rules of
the international order by military
force Mr Johnson has launched a
six-point plan of how the International
Community should resolve the crisis
including sanctions and an attempt to
find a diplomatic solution he will hold
talks with leaders from Canada the
Netherlands and central European
countries in London next week our
political correspondent Joe Pike hasmore
the language the rhetoric from Boris
Johnson here is typically tough aimed at
Vladimir Putin and mirroring what we've
heard from the prime minister in the
last couple of weeks the difference here
is where he is saying it in the New York
Times and it follows those three
interviews Boris Johnson gave to three
different European newspapers yesterday
in Germany Italy and in Spain papers of
record read by opinion formers I think
one of course he wants to try and get a
broad Coalition of support behind his uh
response to Ukraine his idea of how to
respond but also I think in the back of
his mind perhaps he wants to change
perceptions and improve his reputation
he is of course a controversial figure
among some on the European continent
because of his role in brexit and in the
U.S particularly on the Democratic side
of politics some view him with a little
suspicion perhaps because of his
relationship with President Trump but
also comments he's made in the past
about bracket Obama and his attitude
towards Northern Ireland all of this is
a Prelude though these media
interventions are a Prelude to a week of
Downing Street a diplomacy starting
tomorrow when Justin Trudeau of Canada
and Mark Rutter of the Netherlands
Netherlands arrive at number 10 for
talks then on Tuesday leaders of the V4
for uh central European nations will be
in London those are the leaders of the
Czech Republic Poland Hungary and
Slovakia no doubt Boris Johnson does
really believe in the role that the UK
can play in this crisis and the response
to what Vladimir Putin has done but also
perhaps he sees an opportunity to
improve his slightly battered reputation
home and abroad
well the premier league has continued to
show solidarity with Ukraine following
Russia's Invasion Jackie is here with me
now and Jackie football again standing
with Ukraine yeah football stands
together you know is the motto and there
were plenty of flags yesterday there
were lots of screens with the split
Ukrainian flag yellow and blue and as
you can see there on the picture around
the grounds and if this happened before
every single Premier League match and it
was all fine everybody was observing it
and it was all going very well except in
the Chelsea match against Burley when
the fans there decided that during the
minutes Applause they would chant Rowan
abramovich's name let's have a listen
[Applause]
as you can hear they were booed by the
Burnley fans and Thomas tuckel spoke
afterwards he was not pleased he said
this was not a moment for other messages
we do it for Ukraine there is not a
second opinion in this situation we
should stand together and I just think
he was pretty Furious actually that the
fans had chosen that moment to do that
and there was lots of tributes as well
in Australia as they woke up to the news
the very sad news that Shane Warne
um had passed away and there were people
dropping off flowers and beer cans at
his statue
at the MCG
people are still in shock there in
Australia there's been some breaking
news in the last hour that the premier
of Victoria Dan Andrews who offered a
state funeral to the family the family
have accepted uh the state funeral offer
and there'll be more details in the
final uh in the next few days but um he
will have a state funeral and they will
name a stand after him at the MCG and
his manager James Erskine has been
speaking out about the shock they are
all still feeling
the three children who are in complete
shock I think they um you know I spoke
to them yesterday and again and I think
they you know
um Jackson just said we just expect him
to walk in the door this is like a bad
dream and uh spoke to Simone who was
really upset and obviously uh Keith
um Shane's father is you know a pretty
strong individual but you know like
everybody he's just shattered they can't
believe what's happened
it is unbelievable isn't it 52. I should
imagine they're all absolutely broken
um it was it was very interesting to see
Miss Hurley's um messages on Instagram
yesterday you know absolutely
heartbroken and I you know I I did a
piece on Shane warne's book and you know
he dedicates the whole chapter to his
relationship with Elizabeth Hurley and
you know she was one of the loves of his
life and you know she's absolutely
devastated as well it's just all it is
all very Bleak and horrible news
hello again we've got some um a few
updates on the Russian invasion of
Ukraine this morning Dr Tedros he's the
head of the World Health Organization he
has just tweeted and retweeted a who
tweet saying that who has confirmed
several attacks on Health Care in
Ukraine causing multiple deaths and
injuries additional reports are being
investigated attacks on Healthcare
facilities all workers breach medical
neutrality and our violations of
international humanitarian law and then
below the Tweet you can see that he's
tweeted to who retweeted it saying that
who has published six verified reports
of attacks on Health Care in Ukraine so
that is Dr Tedros saying that there are
serious violations of international
humanitarian law taking place also the
Ukrainian Armed Forces general staff
this morning have said that more than 11
000 Russian troops have been killed
since Moscow launched in innovation of
Ukraine on February 24th so that is
Reuters
they are quoting the Ukrainian Armed
Forces general staff obviously that
comes from the ukrainians and it is
unverified a day earlier it put the
Russian casualties at over 10 000. so
there's a couple of updates for you
um on the Russian invasion of Ukraine
it's day 11 now now hundreds of people
gathered in London's Trafalgar Square
which was one of two protests planned
this weekend in London with more
scheduled around the country today some
of those present at the protest
described the support needed for their
families and relatives in Ukraine who
have stayed to fight let's speak now to
Valeria she's a Ukrainian national who
lives in London and his family is
joining the fight against the Russian
invasion Valeria thank you so much for
talking to us this morning how are you
and how is your family
hi
I don't these past days I don't answer
that question anymore because I don't
know what to say and I don't ask these
questions from from the people who are
in Ukraine at the moment because most of
my family is in Ukraine most of my
friends are in Ukraine
um and there is just no answer
do you speak to them
yes
I speak to them well I speak to some I
don't speak to others because many of
them are in the Army oriented of
territorial defense units so that they
don't have enough time to talk many of
my friends are volunteering to deliver
food to the areas that are now starving
because of the because of the Russian
invasion what areas are those Valeria
near Kiev like these are the suburbs of
Kiev where the situation is really
um really difficult it's back and forth
between the Russian control so the
Russian army controls it or not Army I
don't know who is there exactly but the
Russian forces and the Ukrainian forces
and then it's kind of goes back and
forth and and there is no humanitarian
Corridor so that the Russians agree to
have a humanitarian Corridor
um then they shelled the whole
humanitarian corridors when people were
about to leave the the areas
um so there was they were not able to
evacuate people or deliver anything and
so the Red Cross isn't working because
the Red Cross only works when they're
actually humanitarian doors but Russians
obviously are using Barbarian attacks on
civilians and they're also not allowing
people to evacuate or deliver medicine
goods and I've been spending my time
between helping my friends evacuate
newborns from from Kiev in Irby and
bucha which is the suburbs of Kiev where
they have no they have no nappies they
have no
no food mothers have no milk so there's
it's just devastating and that bombing
of the humanitarian corridors that was
in Mario poll yesterday they agreed and
then they they went ahead and bombed it
so let's just talk about it was in
European as well they agreed to evacuate
people on near Kiev but then they
started shooting them that was a picture
of the collapsed bridge if I'm not
mistaken wasn't it one of them yes so
let's talk about the
um the practicalities of what you're
doing I mean you said you're helping
people evacuate newborns from Kiev how
do you go about doing that you're here
in London so how do you go about doing
that what else are you doing we have a
lot of networks of different people so I
I have different contacts of people
doing different things in Kiev either
delivering food or delivering medicines
to older people or delivering so I have
a network of um young mothers who are
helping pregnant women or women just
after birth they're helping them trying
to deliver
um nappies and other things that they
may need in the first days so how do you
how do you get them to them if you don't
mind me asking well sometimes we get
them to them sometimes we don't
depending on what is happening on the
ground
um so people there in Kiev they they now
have a lot of different cars that people
have donated to them for volunteering
purposes for humanitarian Aid or
um or needs of delivery food to our
forces even
um and and I I am coordinating a lot of
it because I receive a lot of requests
from different people around Kiev or
even around the country to be honest
like I get requests from marupal or from
boltaba from near sume because Sumi is
also a hot spot and then I I'm I know a
lot of people in different areas as well
who are working on those so I kind of
transfer that information and then I
help with donations and coordinating
with donors and coordinating with
different expatriate communities in
London but also in other countries like
Netherlands Germany people are helping
from everywhere and I'm just there's a
lot of work to be done on coordinating
of all of these efforts to make sure
that the efforts are helpful it's
extraordinary that in such a short time
this network what is what sounds like is
a network has sprung up um I want to ask
you because we are running out of time
here but how do people get involved in
this effort because a lot of people will
want to do something they'll be seeing
what's going on they'll be seeing all
those people fleeing and they'll want to
do something so how do they yes they can
go to the protest but how do they
actually provide you with support
exactly exactly a very good question so
one there is a website which is called
defend ukraine.org where you can go and
find information on various directions
of work including donations humanitarian
support boycotting Russia what you can
do to help kind of cut ties with Russia
and destroy their economy so that they
finally realize what they're doing is
unacceptable and you can also go to for
example in London there is a Ukrainian
club and there is also Ukrainian Embassy
in London who who both are helping
people direct their efforts into the
right direction so that the donations
are helpful so that the closer they're
bringing is actually something that
people need there
um and and they have all the other
different work streams where they can
advise on what's what's the best
um okay
so we're gonna have to leave it there
but Valera thank you so much thanks a
lot for talking to us thank you
now President zielinski says that
Ukraine will receive more starlink
internet terminals next week following a
conversation with Elon Musk Mr zielinski
said in a tweet that he's grateful to
the SpaceX Chiefs for supporting Ukraine
with words and deeds last week Mr musk
warned that Stalin could be targeted as
Internet is disrupted in Ukraine it's
the only active non-russian
Communications system
the Chinese foreign minister Wang Yi has
told the U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken that China opposes any moves
that add fuel to the flames in Ukraine
China has broken ranks with Europe and
the U.S on imposing sanctions against
Russia and called for negotiation to
resolve the crisis
meanwhile U.S officials have traveled to
Venezuela for talks with the country's
government to determine whether or not
they're prepared to drop their close
ties with Russia the trip is the highest
level U.S visits to Venezuela since the
two countries broke diplomatic relations
amid a campaign of U.S sanctions
coming up on Sky News breakfast we'll
take another look at this morning's
papers with the entrepreneur Kate
Hardcastle and the presenter and writer
Matthew stadley
[Music]
the entrepreneur Kate Hardcastle and the
presenter and writer Matt Stadler and
good morning to you both thanks a lot
for joining us Kate do you want to kick
us off seven pounds a gallon for oil
page four day one
many of us didn't see the the day when
we uh we would see that price at the
pumps and obviously Fuel and the impact
of that cost and that open market and
that push for demand that was already
happening because of the demand post
lockdown has now exacerbated as the
World Market has certainly challenged
with what's happening in Russia and the
Ukraine and whilst this article very
much focuses on a call from RAC and
other bodies to try and do something
with the vat rate I think we have to
remember obviously the impact of field
goes so much further it's a key
ingredient to most of uh the things we
buy the food that we buy the haulage of
the food we buy and the goods that we
buy so a huge impact for businesses and
manufactured goods too absolutely whilst
we turn our attention to things like
this fuel the cost of living crisis in
the UK there's absolutely no lack of
understanding from me of the real
civilian crisis that's going on
elsewhere but this is a real challenging
time for so many families we had those
headlines just a month ago people having
to make the choice between Heating and
eating this is going to carry on in
terms of the cost of living crisis right
through and I fear for Autumn where I
think the impact will be most felt it's
so interesting when we were talking
about the cost of living crisis this is
really
just not something that we would ever
would have anticipated Matt it's really
going to get hard for a lot of people
isn't it
yeah there's absolutely no doubt that
the crisis in Ukraine is piling on the
misery for people up and down the
country as Kate was saying we've already
got a cost of living crisis people
choosing between Heating and eating
we've got that huge energy hike I just
got my email through this week from my
supplier saying my prices are going to
go we've got that around the corner and
huge inflation and now because of what's
going on in in Ukraine because of
Putin's monstrosity it's going to hurt
even more but I think we have to accept
that when we're watching children being
murdered by the Russian dictator we have
to take our own share of the pain on
this and while we have imposed sanctions
it is true to say that Europe is still
addicted to Russian gas and oil and in
other words we are pumping billions of
pounds a week into Putin's war effort
because we have not cut off his gas
supply So to that extent we continue to
be complicit okay what do you think is
this something that we're gonna have to
act on
sooner rather than later
the UK isn't as reliant on that but we
buy from a World Market and that's where
the price is born out of and I think we
are taking actions you asked me earlier
and we were cut short in terms of are we
doing enough no one's ever going to feel
I don't think that we're doing enough
when that Bloodshed that everyday terror
is piling out all of us are watching on
in absolute horror wanting to do
everything we can and feeling pretty
helpless I think we've got to make sure
that the intensity increases day by day
and I think what I am pleased to have
seen is a stepping up of organizations
Charities and just people like you and I
out there trying to do everything that
we can do to support this is never going
to feel enough
Matt let's have a look at the front page
of the Sunday Mirror a striking picture
just one of so many that are coming out
of this crisis
yeah we've seen all week haven't we the
quiet breathtaking bravery of people in
Ukraine that's why I say we have to be
prepared to accept pain ourselves and
this picture is in the Southeastern City
I think of militar and it went viral
yesterday these are unarmed Ukrainian
civilians facing down Russian invading
soldiers who are firing into the air and
forcing them to retreat and one of the
big stories of this war is that Russian
soldiers I think many of them didn't
realize that they were going to war and
those that did thought they'd be
welcomed with open arms by their fellow
Slavs and of course that has been very
very far from the reality we also know
in Kaizen which is in the south of
Ukraine as well it's the only major
Ukrainian City to have been captured by
the Russians there's also been
incredible Defiance 2 000 people I think
yesterday out on the streets and that
extraordinary image of a Ukrainian
protester putting a Ukrainian flag on a
Russian attacked as I was saying in the
last hour we've also seen Ukrainian
Farmers literally Towing away Russian
heavy armored vehicles and The Bravery
of the Ukrainian people which has
followed The Bravery of their
extraordinary president kalensky I think
this is a this should inspire all of us
to do our bit
and a lot of people have come out
haven't they um and joined these
protests Guardian online they see tens
of thousands joined rallies really
around the world
that's right yes and there has been the
public outcry the uh cities like New
York and Paris full of tens of thousands
of protesters many of them raising the
sunflower the national flower of the
Ukraine uh placards reading piece is
wanted there is certainly many uh people
wanting to have their voice heard
wanting to come together wanting to stop
the the Bloodshed and the terror and I I
think that it is for many people not not
anywhere near the feeling that they can
do enough many people rallying to get
donations uh to uh organizations that
are going to try to get those items that
we've just heard in your last feature
the nappies that need to get there the
Sanitary products that need to get there
this is about people trying to do the
right thing when I feel they feel
incredibly Limited in what they can do
it's heartbreaking
it's heartbreaking all around isn't it
Matt and Kate thank you so much for
talking to us and being with us this
morning hopefully next time we'll have a
bit more I don't know happier news to
talk about but thank you so much enjoy
your Sunday both
coming up in the next hour on Sky News
breakfast The Who confirms several
attacks on Healthcare in Ukraine causing
multiple deaths and injuries as Russia
assaults continues
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign